now there's this guy bill gates now bill
gates if you don't know him he's this
soy drinking rather grotesque his body
have you seen the picture maybe we can
get the picture that connor could throw
it in a little bit that picture of him
in the sweater it's really quite
horrible um
but he created microsoft he created
windows uh windows of course and
microsoft i mean these were products
that although they were ubiquitous and
they were on everybody's computers and
you know microsoft paint was nice and
all that they had gillian viruses on
them right every time you opened up your
pc there were a million viruses
everything would be slowed down pop-ups
blah blah blah well
he brought us the virus on the computer
and now he's somehow seemingly trying to
save us from covet and everything else
you may remember this video from a while
back how do we prevent something where
we don't even understand how it came to
be like you know are there labs where
they need to do better at
you know enclosing the work that they're
doing i understand that they have to do
the work but how do we figure that out
and how do we move forward in that realm
well we shouldn't be careful about lab
safety
it's quite clear in this case that it
came across through animals and almost
all our diseases like hiv crossed over
from chimpanzees in africa quite some
time ago ebola came from bats uh
this also uh with one step in between
came
uh from bats so it's going to keep
happening particularly climate change
where we're invading uh a lot of
habitats
and you want to catch it as soon as you
can how do we do that well you see
people getting sick
you
you see
elevated deaths and you go in there and
you actually take and you sequence it
early on
and then you have a global group right
that is ready to go kind of like a fire
squad
comes in and very quickly you diagnose
people
he's just such a weirdo freak i don't
even know what to say like what does he
have to do with covet response now i get
it he's got a lot of money and when you
have a lot of money people seem to think
that you know everything about
everything and he's got his foundations
and all of these things but again he
created software and what did that
software do it got put on basically
every computer and then every computer
got endlessly infected with viruses i
don't think that's much of a jump to
sort of what's going on now exactly why
he's involved so involved in our modern
virus situation then he tweeted this out
yesterday and i had to go after him for
it he said movies like outbreak nailed
it when they imagined a global disease
fighting team who is ready to respond to
a crisis on a moment's notice now we
need to make it a reality
outbreak the whole
movie basically is about how corrupt the
government and everything and the whole
system is and then yes a few people i
guess eventually he shoots the little
monkey and they save the people okay
fine anyway he tweeted that out and i
felt like i got him with this retweet i
i felt this was pretty good everyone
hates you and that's why you shut your
replies on all your tweets you
megalomaniacal soyboy weirdo um i feel
like i nailed that one uh candace owens
though she's pretty solid when it comes
to responding to these people too she
has a way that we can respond to the
next pandemic and that's just soy boy
bill gates in jail if you think i'm
being a little unfair with the with the
soy and everything here it's just like
no you got to go away man and we have to
mock these people into oblivion what
does bill gates have to do with your
life or my life did anyone vote for bill
gates did anyone say bill gates should
be in charge of our health or our
vaccinations or any of these things but
we've got plenty of proof
that their policies are terrible the
policies of the democrats of the left of
the machine when it comes to lockdowns
vaxes mask mandates they do it all
for
political gain and they tell us they're
doing it and for some reason a certain
amount of people seem to just love
it foreign